[Applause]
yeah some guy called over here but
doctor he's looking for a driver you
interested I am NOT a medical doctor I'm
a musician
I'm about to embark on a concert to work
in the deep south what other experience
do you have
public relations do you foresee any
issues in working for a black man you
and the deep south three problems
promise me you're gonna write me or
water the friends some dental smell but
I've never had fried chicken at my life
people love the fried chicken you have a
very narrow assessment of me Tony Yeah
right I'm good we'll be interacting with
some of the wealthiest people in the
country it is my feeling that your
diction wolf could use some finessing
why you break my balls because you can
do better mr. bat along the Lord I saw
dr. Shirley play the piano it's like a
genius I think come on gotta throw
enough to get grease on my blanket or my
blankie
this gentleman says that I'm not
permitted to dine here I'm afraid not
how does he smile and shake their hands
like that
because it takes courage to change
people's cars what are you doing I'm uh
de Leon
dear Dolores sometimes you remind me of
a house you know this is pathetic right
but this time the distance between us is
breaking my spirit falling in love with
you was the easiest thing I have ever
done
pitas kissing kids that's like clinging
a cowbell at the end of Shostakovich is
seven that's good it's perfect oh never
win with violence you only win will you
maintain your dignity people you mr.
bigshot doing concerts for rich people
so if I'm not black enough if I'm not
white enough territory whatever my
anyone can sound like Beethoven your
music will you do oh you can do that
[Music]
what do we do about the bones we do this
pick it up Tony squirrels would eat it
anyway
pick it up
[Music]